ce matin c'est sébastien lecornu bonjour
monsieur le ministre bonjour c'était
notre invitation ministre d outre-mer en
étant 100 pendant 20 minutes est à mes
côtés pour cette interview patrick roger
journaliste au monde
bonjour patrick à vous suivez avec
attention à l'actualité des outre mer on
va bien sûr en parler avec vous
longuement sébastien lecornu
mais d'abord cette gifle reçue hier par
le président de la république est une
condamnation unanime unanime de la part
de toute la classe politique qu'est ce
que ce geste 10 de notre démocratie pour
vous est ce qu'elle est malade
aujourd'hui à coup sûr l ema la pièce
tout une violence qui monte dans la
société et on le sent bien je pense que
le président république et dans
l'interview qu'il a donnée là il dit
deux chaussées ont pas de banalité du
mal et d'ailleurs moi je me réjouis que
les condamnations je suis une énigme
parce que après tout on aurait pu aussi
craindre que parfois éviter une rupture
de ce point de vue ça n'a pas été le cas
donc pas de banalisation de ce merdier
de la part de qui la largue nord mais je
dire hier ça avait de l'alluré à
l'assemblée nationale quand chaque
groupe l'un après l'autre
quelles que soient les sensibilités
politiques si on ne touche pas au
président de la république parce que il
y a évidemment dimension insulaire et
accessoirement on ne touche aucun être
humain parce que la violence ne fait pas
partie des violences physiques comme
verbales mais encore plus physique ne
fait pas partie de nos valeurs et de
notre culture
évidemment ça fait du bien de l'entendre
c'est ce que j'appelle lutter contre la
banalisation de ce mal dans lequel on
accepte année après année semaine après
semaine qu'un chauffeur de bus se fasse
agresser que des policiers ou des
pompiers soit caillaissé que des maires
soient agressés dans le cadre de leurs
fonctions que le président de la
république soit victime d'une gifle donc
ça je pense que c'est essentiel aussi
qu'on refasse un peu nation et qu'on
refuse cette banalisation et puis en
même temps le président l'a fait
d'angles dans son interview il faut
aussi prendre un tout petit peu de
hauteur et relativiser je crois que
c'est le mot qui n'en payent relativiser
parce que ben nous nous sommes protégés
par la police c'est pas le cas des mères
charge symbolique aussi des des maires y
met un peu sur le même plan l'agression
dont il a été victime et les agressions
dont sont victimes les verts vous c'est
vous vous avez porté la loi engagement
et proximité qui a été porté après la
mort du maire de sign on s'en souvient
c'était de cet événement dramatique ça
renforcer la protection juridique des
mères
z psychologique leur pouvoir de police
est ce qu'il faut aller plus loin dans
les sanctions envers les agresseurs
d'élus pour vous il ya déjà des réponses
pénales qui sont lourdes et importantes
à dire jeu on va attendre de voir ce que
l'anc est dit mais j'ai cru comprendre
que les personnes hier qu'ils ont voulu
agresser présents dans le public sont
des personnes qui n'étaient pas connus
des services de justice est bien là où
est le problème si je pense qu'il faut
pas non plus dans une course à
l'échalote en permanence nouvelles lois
nouvelles mesures on a juste à faire
aussi à des personnes qui elle-même
verse dans cette violence ou dans cette
grande radicalité donc faut aussi
combattre le mal à la racine et c'est
vrai que lorsqu'on dit que cette
violence physique elle démarre par une
violence verbale et réseaux sociaux
malheureusement foisonnent aussi d'un
carburant pour se faire avec une
libération aussi des actes au petit à
petit quand on condamne pas les lignes
rouges sur le bien et le mal pardon de
le dire aussi simplement que ça mais
sont des lignes rouges qui ne sont plus
clairement identifiés par tout à chacun
et malheureusement le sont franchies non
je pense que c'est bien de condamner
c'est bien de lutter contre cette
banalisation et de fait le point commun
entre le président républicain policier
ou un maire c'est la puissance publique
c'est à dire c'est celles et ceux qui
s'engagent alors après certains portant
l'uniforme certains sont armés certains
sont protégés donc ne sont pas ça c'est
bien et nous rions d'égalité on renoue
l'éventaire et la réalité
l'agresseur de forces de l'ordre est ce
qu'il faut prendre des l'excusé jamais
appliquées par l'autorité judiciaire
le problème à chaque fois c'est la
preuve moi je me suis savez je juge
avait d'ailleurs dit parfois aussi dans
l'hémicycle au sénat qu'il fallait pas
non plus verser dans une forme de
démagogie alors on était à quelques
semaines des élections sénatoriales
certains collectionneurs
parfois on en rajoute et quelques
louches ça fait sûrement partie du jeu
l'arrêté c'est de faire preuve
bien souvent quand vous avez un maire
qui est agressée et il faut qu'il arrive
à démontrer devant l'autorité judiciaire
la nature la qualité de ses agresseurs
comment ça c'est ça s'est passé c'est
particulièrement vrai avec les
installations par exemple de gens du
voyage qui sont malheureusement où c'est
très très bien une des sources de
violence
coquelles les maires ou adjoints au
maire dayori et conseillers municipaux
sont confrontés donc notre sujet c'est
le système de preuves capacité à établir
les faits devant l'autorité judiciaire
et sa soif à malmener notre état de
droit et à écrire n'importe quoi dans la
loi de la république
c'est pas une loi qui va le régler donc
la folie travail et la vidéoprotection
par exemple moi je
je sais qu'en tant que candidat aux
élections départementales permettez-moi
de le dire dans leur on va justement
massivement déployées la vidéoprotection
parce que ça permet de capter des
preuves devant l'autorité judiciaire et
l'on va parler des autres maires
longuement on commence par la crise
sanitaire patrick d'abord fait peut-être
un point de situation dans les autres
mers il y avait quelques inquiétudes en
guyane notamment inégal partout depuis
le début est en fête et pas une crise
sanitaire ya une crise sanitaire par
territoire et c'est vrai que c'est
toujours un peu désagréable pour nos
concitoyens ultramarins de voir que dans
l'hexagone parfois on les confine
pendant comprendre des mesures de
restriction dans certains territoires et
vice et versa aujourd'hui une situation
qui revient quasiment à la normale aux
antilles avec une exception à saint
martin sur lesquels les chiffres sont
malheureusement pas très bon mais sur
lequel on a des mesures de couvre-feu et
une vaccination qu'on cherche à
accélérer
qui vont-ils situation saint martin du
coup les mesures à bas le mesures sont
maintenus le sujet c'est la coopération
avec la partie hollandaise puisqu'on est
sur une île dans le calendrier un
partage souveraineté et donc c'est
parfois là où c'était plus difficile de
mobiliser tout ça non la vraie situation
que nous observons de près c'est
évidemment la guyane vous l'avez dit sur
lequel tout incident cyr soir était
autour de 300 avec une vaccination qui
avance assez lentement on a un
confinement qui est qui est actuellement
en cours à ses thématisée en fonction
des déçoit d'élus soit évidemment des
degrés de d'acceptabilité de certaines
ouvertures en terme de circulation de
l'épidémie en tout cas le chiffre
diminue la tension hospitalier avait
forte d'ailleurs les praticiens
hospitaliers appel massivement à ce que
nos concitoyens se vaccine que la seule
réponse de protection évidemment pour la
population la réunion mayotte on a des
taux d'incidence qui sont bas à mayotte
qui reste assez élevé à la réunion
autour de 150 le sujet évidemment c'est
la circulation des variants la guyane
variant brésilien
mayotte et la réunion variant sud
africain qui rend toujours mine de rien
la situation fragile c'est pour ça qu'on
observe de près vous avez mis en place
une procédure de levée progressive des
motifs des motifs impérieux aujourd'hui
malgré tout le
le député a l'air bon sens kamardine
concernant mayotte
vous accuse de tenir les mahorais comme
des chiens on essaie de les enfermer en
cash c'est violent quand même pourquoi
ces mesures sont elles maintenues à
mayotte
non j'ai une amitié pour mon sur caméra
d'im il ya des mots qu'il faut pas
employer alors je sais qu'on est en
campagne électorale que parfois il faut
dire des choses fortes pour se faire
entendre c'est sûrement cela on va
mettre ça sur ce compte là mais non
parce que l'inversé on dirait aussi
qu'on ne protège pas les mahoraises et
les mahorais bon les mêmes parfois nous
ont reproché d'être trop tardif dans
l'envoi de vaccins alors que pourtant
nous étions sur les premiers territoires
de la république à être livrées en
vaccins et ensuite ce sont les mêmes qui
parfois n'encourage pas à la vaccination
les mêmes nous ont parfois reproché de
prendre des mesures de restrictions trop
tardivement et ensuite nous reprochent
de les maintenir trop longtemps je pense
qu'il faut pas faire de politique avec
cette crise sanitaire
mayotte a connu des moments très très
difficiles le taux d'incidence qui était
à plus de 1000 avec un invariant sud
africain qui était qui circulait à
grande vitesse aujourd'hui il est une
évidence que la présence de the orient
nous oblige à prendre des mesures de
précaution et pardon faut finir ses
phrases
dès lors que la vaccination n'avance pas
assez vite et c'est là où je compte sur
mon sur l'ensemble des candidats aux
élections départementales à mayotte
aussi pour pour porter un message
d'adhésion parce que il y avait la
guerre - caen métropole bat déjà les
taux d'incidence parfois sont très bas
donc mon ne sort pas de mesures de
restriction comme on vient de le vivre
la dent caisse est ce sentiment que
c'est bon on l'a eue c'est derrière soi
c'est un peu humain mais ça il faut
lutter contre cette idée là parce que
malheureusement l'épidémie peut nous
revenir parfois vous avez aussi quelques
groupuscules sur les réseaux sociaux ou
ailleurs qui s'agitent et qui font de la
politique anti vaccins comme on comme on
dit si bien en agitant les peurs en
disant que en faisant aussi parfois des
raccourcis avec avec l'histoire qui sont
nées des raccourcis qui franchement
donne dans notre coeur donc voilà je
pense aussi que la réalité c'est que la
capacité à redonner toutes les libertés
de circulation etc à l'ensemble de ses
territoires et compris les territoires
insulaires parce qu'on
une épidémie dans un territoire fermé
par définition différemment il ya un chu
en général quand il est à saturation bas
on ne peut pas faire d'évacuation
sanitaire sur d'autres territoires qui
eux mêmes parfois sont fermés enfin tout
ça est un peu difficile
la réponse c'est de vaccins c'est la
vaccination c'est du finder ou du
moderna en grand nombre depuis le début
il ya les bras pour piquer parce que le
personnel soignant est complètement
engagé et parlant de très direct ce qui
manque c'est les bras à piquer bon là
donc faut aussi dire les choses
on a un retard désormais qui est qu un
retard que j'ai du mal à accepter le non
pas une acceptabilité politique mais je
me dis mince quand on voit les pays dans
le monde dans lequel les gens n'ont pas
la chance d'accéder à un système de
soins ou à des stocks de vaccins et que
nous nous pouvons le faire je me dis
quelque chose de dommages ou alors je le
dis comme ça c'est un cri du coeur un
mot juste sur la guyane ce que vous
dites à la situation est assez
inquiétant ça va vous avez maintenu les
élections sur place est ce que ça se
tiendra dans des conditions
particulières où ce seront 10 yongkang
métropole n'avait pas de religion sur le
sujet pour être honnête donc on a saisi
le conseil scientifique on a mené une
consultation etc et mère parce qu'après
tout c'est eux qui organisent aussi le
scrutin l'arrêter c'est que on sait
tenir un scrutin dans les règles de
l'art sanitaire avec les mesures
barrières le sujet c'était la campagne
bon on fait campagne différemment gun
que dans l'eure beaucoup de choses se
font à l'extérieur par les
rassemblements se font à l'air libre
mais on est quand même dans des
organisations de campagne qui sont
différentes et on n'a pas observé de
comportement de la part des colistiers
des candidats qui viendra à l'encontre
de ces mesures barrières donc en fait
dès lors qu' une responsabilité
collective collective c'est pas que
l'état on sait aussi les maires mais
aussi les candidats aussi militant une
responsabilité collective de la manière
de mener cette campagne
le scrutin peut être tenus dans les
délais je rappelle que le principe de
ces deux conditions
oui doyen le principe c'est de tenir les
élections dans les temps dans une
démocratie c'était l'exception qui nous
aurait amenés à repousser ces élections
et une partie poehl des autres maires
des économies d'outre-mer sont fortement
dépendants d'eux
de l'activité touristique du secteur
touristique ce conseil notamment aux
antilles à la réunion
actuellement même à la nouette la
nouvelle calédonie où la polynésie où la
polynésie
comment faire en sorte que l'activité
touristique puissent reprendre
basée aujourd'hui elle va reprendre
parce que lorsqu'on lève les motifs
impérieux pour les personnes vaccinées
dans tous les territoires parce que pour
le coup il ya une réalité c'est quand on
est vacciné l'accès plus facile que
lorsqu'on les par et pour des raisons
qu'on peut complètement comprendre et
ben vous êtes une reprise de l'économie
touristique dès qu'on a fait ces
annonces on a constaté que les
différents opérateurs touristiques vous
voyez des réservations se faire deux
pays d'être très différents et compris
des européens c'est particulièrement
vrai en polynésie c'est particulièrement
vrai saint barth pour prendre ce qu'elle
plus visible mais c'est tout aussi vrai
à la réunion en martinique et en
guadeloupe et donc on va vers une
reprise progressive
je vous rappelle que nous avions pris
des mesures plutôt courageuse pour
sauver la saison
à noël dans lequel on avait réussi en
capsules et quinze jours de devis
touristique pour les fêtes de fin
d'année qui n'avait pas entraîné une
reprise de l'épidémie en janvier ce
qu'on avait des protocoles tellement
strictes que tout cela avait plutôt bien
fonctionné il faut le reconnaître on a
eu malheureusement une partie de la
saison un peu un peu flingue et il faut
bien reconnaître février mars cette
période de divers ici dans lequel il ya
évidemment des opportunités importantes
là bas c'est comme ça les chiffres
n'étaient pas bons désormais on a cette
reprise à partir d'aujourd'hui avec en
plus des compagnies aériennes qui joue
jeu qui mène un certain nombre de
promotions sur sur leurs offres
commerciales et donc ça va dans le bon
sens vous encourager les français à
passer leurs vacances d'été dans les
autres mers avec le pass à lithaire
faudra les deux métropoles dans les
tactiques en étant vacciner le pass
sanitaire s'est jamais qu'une
manière de présenter ces documents ce
qui compte c'est d'être vacciné et de
l'or vous admire de passani terre soit
vous êtes vacciné sur vous faites un
test pcr de toute façon pour spcr pour
les outre mers parce que il affirme nous
outre-mer les met au contact de pays
dans la zone qu'ils peuvent toujours
nous exposer aux variants le tsp cers
notre capacité à détecter si les gens
sont malades ou pas et à séquencer
ensuite le test positif pour savoir de
quelle variante il s'agit donc en fait
on gardera des tests pcr pour tous les
outre-mer ou antigénique en tout cas le
cas échéant quoi qu'il arrive pour ceux
qui sont vaccinées y aura pas de test et
à stopper serre et compris pour ceux qui
sont vaccinées ça je suis formel là
dessus et pardon c'est un moyen de
protéger les populations locales
donc là on rigole pas avec ça pardon
mais je pense que désormais on vit tous
avec ça j'ai dû en faire moins une
vingtaine de tests pcr donc c'est
important de préciser qu'à patienter
ça permet de contrôler les flux et
s'assurer que si invariants circulent
être en situation de m en protection les
populations le cas échéant donc avec le
test avec la vaccination on a une
reprise de l'activité touristique qui
peut se refaire à la normale on va aller
la nouvelle calédonie patrick oui on
sort d'une d'une semaine de travaux
intenses et des échanges fructueux a
priori entre les différentes composantes
même s'il en manquait finalement qu'une
une date a été arrêtée pour sceller de
l'état qui a fixé la date du 12 décembre
pour la la troisième consultation et
qu'il va refaire la sortie de l'accord
de nouméa
comment quel quel retour avez vous déjà
là-bas sur place vont continuer
évidemment avoir eu des contacts avec
l'ensemble des délégations qui sont
venus à paris mais aussi une partie de
la société civile parce que faut pas
oublier que tout ça n'est pas qu'une
affaire entre politique et que désormais
plus de 280 mille personnes qui sont
inquiètes de leur avenir quelle que soit
leur origine quel que soit le camp dans
lequel entre guillemets elle se situe le
oui ou le non à l'indépendance
non je pense que là il faut tracer le
chemin entre maintenant et le 12
décembre prochain
continuez d'avancer sur le document du
oui et du non vous savez pour la
première fois on a on a travaillé sur
les réponses on a voulu montrer ce que
pour l'état en implications juridiques
financières en droit international
ce que voulait dire ce oui ce que
voulait dire ce nom leschi certaines
positions notamment du côté s'éclairer
mais des deux côtés un faut pas penser
que ce n'est que du côté des
indépendantistes je pense que le nom
c'est pas indépendantiste n'était
vraiment si c'est indépendant
indépendantiste d'un côté et
autonomistes de l'autre donc donné aussi
du corps et du sens au projet des
autonomistes
elle veut tout aussi d'importance pour
l'état moi ça me semble intéressant en
tout cas tout autant on à écrire et se
mouiller ce nom désormais il ya un
document qui doit sortir qui va faire
l'objet d'une ultime consultation de la
part de la société cible notamment du
monde économique celle que vous avez des
chapitres entiers dans le document qui
concerne les questions monétaires les
applications bancaires
la question des accords commerciaux ça
ça intéresse directement le monde
économique donc il faut qu'on arrive
évidemment à partager ce document avait
que l'on y arrivera
il sortira qu'en dans les jours qui
viennent on tient là un tiens un
calendrier assez resserrée et puis bien
sûr nouer des relations continues est de
nouer des relations ça c'est déjà fait
mais avec ces et ceux qui étaient
absents mentalement l'uni de partants
quatre semaines il ya des rapprochements
qui se sont effectués oui clairement
sinon on n'aurait pas eu cette
déclaration du gouvernement qui traduit
quand même une convergence sur un
certain nombre de choses pas la date
clairement la date du 12 décembre c'est
le choix du gouvernement
combien calédonienne ne pas valider ce
choix de date
en revanche la stratégie qui consiste à
se dire on éclaire le oui et le non on
conforte et on consolide et ont sécurisé
la fin de l'accord de nouméa 1998 a
maintenant avec ce troisième référendum
le 12 décembre prochain
et derrière on vient donner une période
de transition de visible
et de stabilité qui permet de savoir ce
qui se passe le jour d'après en cas de
oui en cas de non pour aller vers une
énième consultation enfin ultime
consultation pour le coup celle de 2023
qui dira en cas de oui quelle est la
relation quelle constitution déjà pour
cette est indépendant et quelle est la
relation entre la france et cet état de
canac indépendants ou en cas de non quel
est le lien qu'elle est quelles sont les
institutions de la nouvelle calédonie
dans le cadre de la république
voilà on a enfin une séquence qui est
désormais lisible visible qui crée la
stabilité pour l'ensemble des acteurs
calédonien monsieur pour la population
certains parmi ceux qui n'étaient pas
présents à paris évoque à demi mot
l'hypothèse de la possibilité d'un
boycott du référendum de la consultation
du 12 décembre
vous y croyez sincèrement déjà j'ai noté
que les différentes déclarations
politiques ne l'est pas non sens puis
pardon mais la responsabilité serait de
celles et ceux qui sur ce terrain sera
historique déjà fan elle n'aurait pas de
sens ça n'aurait pas de sens vis-à-vis
du processus de décolonisation dans
lequel nous sommes engagés devant les
nations unies
dire que ceux là mêmes devront répondre
devant les nations unies que le
processus ne peut pas aller correctement
et convenablement jusqu'au bout nous
nous tenons parole l'accord de nouméa va
jusqu'à son terme
on tient parole parce qu'on organise ce
troisième référendum rappelez vous il ya
encore quelques mois certains de me
demander de constater que l'accord de
nouméa à déterminer il n'est pas
question donc dès lors qu'on organise ce
référendum
tout le monde doit évidemment jouer ce
jeu et donc il n'est pas question
d'aller sur cette tante du boycott pour
les grands responsables politiques
indépendantistes
alors après que quelques voix isolées
ici ou là puisse le dire c'est autre
chose quand tout cas je connais sens des
responsabilités des uns et des autres
nous venons de de trop loin dans un
dossier suffisamment complexe pour se
permettre de jouer comme cela avec
l'accord des merveilles
at inquiet sur l'avenir de l'île est ce
que clairement il ya un risque de
partition aujourd'hui la nouvelle
calédonie nantes où l'eau fut cette
partition tout la refuse après qu'il y
ait des réflexions sur l'organisation
politique à l'intérieur de l'archipel de
faire évoluer
éventuellement les compétences des
communes des provinces du gouvernement
et ses bas typiquement c'est ce que
j'appelle moi consultation de projets de
2023 si le nom devait l'emporter une
troisième fois
ben il faudra bien qu'on s'interroge sur
les organisations politiques
calédoniennes il ya des choses qui sont
demandés si le oui l'emporté c'est
encore un autre
un autre champ qui s'ouvre devant nous
mais ces questions seront posées parce
que ce n'est pas de votre responsabilité
mais sincèrement est-ce que la situation
actuelle de blocage du gouvernement
puisque actuellement les
indépendantistes sont incapables de
s'accorder sur la le président et la
vice présidence du gouvernement
est ce que cette situation peut durer
jusqu'aux feux jusqu'au 12 décembre
dans l'absolu ça ne regarde pas le
gouvernement de la république dans
l'absolu je ne suis pas là pour être
dans une ingérence dans les affaires
politiques
mais vous thierry santa expédie les
affaires courantes je viens un
gouvernement collégial
il ya un président du congrès vous savez
que pour celles et ceux qui connaissent
peut être pas bien les organisations
quelle haine mais les provinces et les
communes ont beaucoup de compétences
sont que vous voyez l'instabilité
gouvernementale nous a pas empêchés de
d'avancé sur un certain nombre de sujets
il est clair que pour des raisons de
visibilité et compris davantage
d'ailleurs peut-être par des
investisseurs privés pour le monde
économique
avoir un gouvernement stabiliser
apporterait évidemment beaucoup mais une
fois de plus que ce gouvernement soit
aujourd'hui non formés non constituent
ne nous a pas empêchés de nous réunir
nous a pas empêchés de tracer une
feuille de route de route par les moines
ont pas de bruit mais de route
institutionnels nous a pas empêchés de
d'avancé sur le traitement de la crise
qu vide avec les autorités en place ne
l'empêchent pas le nouveau commissaire
d'arriver en nouvelle calédonie donc non
je pense qu'il faut il faut pas regarder
cette affaire gouvernementale de manière
complètement dirimante dernière question
est-ce que vous avez réunir
prochainement comité d un comité des
signataires
à quelle date et sous quelle forme oui
cet été en tout cas d'ici à l'été et je
chanterai actuellement de mener à
centres de consultation pour l'organiser
dans les meilleures conditions
nouméa après j'attends de voir aussi le
le désir de certains peut-être de venir
à paris ou de revenir un parc et cet été
c'est il ya une date un peu plus présent
quand on va parler de mayotte
vous avez promis un projet de loi
spécifique à mayotte qu'en sera-t-il
présentait on termine les consultations
alors la période évidemment électorale
vient interrompre tout cela et c'est
bien légitime la consultation de bien
fonctionner un pratiquement plus de 1200
personnes y ont participé 300
contributions avec un certain nombre de
taxes sommes dans le projet de loi sur
la convergence économique et social ces
en clair comment on termine la
départementalisation là on est au milieu
du gué et ça ne satisfait personne donc
ne peut pas continuer comme ça une
branche régaliennes évidemment sur la
sécurité de nos concitoyens et sur la
lutte contre l'immigration
une mise à l'échelle aussi d'un certain
nombre de normes qui parfois entravent
le développement économique de mayotte
et puis bientôt une réflexion
institutionnelle sur le conseil
départemental
si on se projette dans 10 ou 15 ans
comment l'institution doit fonctionner
sur les quatre chapitres que j'ai mis
sur la table la consultation c'est donc
bien déroulée l'idée étant de présenter
ce texte en conseil des ministres entre
la fin de l'année entre la fin de cette
année et le début de l'année 2022
donc il est clair qu'on n'aurait pas un
débat parlementaire qui seraient
terminés d'ici à l'élection
présidentielle mais nous le savions au
moment où nous avons mis ce projet de
loi sur sur la table mais en tout cas je
pense que c'est nécessaire de s'inscrire
désormais dans un temps court moyen et
long en tout cas on a fêté les dix ans
la départementalisation de mayotte
il était temps de recréer des
perspectives pour le dit prochaine d'un
conseil des ministres à la fin de
l'année est ce que vous en parlerez
avant est ce qu on connaîtra les grandes
lignes bien sûr l'idée c'est de
retourner devant devant les acteurs
mahorais pour pour faire un premier
retour de des contributions et des
consultations et d'essayer de deux
tracés à l' architecture d'un projet de
loi est le co construire il ya rarement
des lois qui concerne un territoire en
tant que tel on a fait des choses
récemment avec jacqueline gourault sur
l'alsace mais c'est rare d'avoir une une
loi qui est consacré un seul territoire
l'idée c'est d'avoir qu'à une méthode de
construction puis je mets les pieds dans
le plat si on veut éviter aussi qui est
de la récupération politicienne
nationale de ce qui se passe au
quotidien à mayotte il vaut mieux
construire avec les acteurs du
territoire national en disant ça oui
souvent madame le pen quand même prend
en otage mayotte sur twitter à la fois
en se servant ce qui se passe à mayotte
pour dire aux français l'hexagone nous
avez vu ce qui s'y passe est terrible et
donc aussi en stigmatisant ce qui se
passe au quotidien sur sur l'île et en
même temps en faisant croire aux
mahoraises et mahorais qu'elle les
protège ce qui n'est évidemment est
absolument faux pour moi je préfère une
une méthode beaucoup plus pragmatique
très respectueuse et dans lequel on
réaffirme que mayotte c'est la france
qu'on est fier que ce soit france est
donc là aussi pas de l'ambiguïté sur ce
point parce que parfois on lit des
choses dans la presse qui sont toujours
un peu un peu contrariante et connais au
moins 6 et français faut donc aussi une
vraie méthode française de s'adapter
aussi aux problématiques du quotidien
que l'on peut vivre là bas mais vous
aviez annoncé quand même une
présentation des comptes d'un wendel
architecture justement de cette loi
programme en juillet c'est toujours cet
échéancier toujours entre juillet et
septembre
j'attends aussi que les élections
départementales se termine et d'avoir
l'exécutif départemental installé ce
sera par vous le chef de l'état pourrait
s'emparer de ce dossier
on verra comment les choses se feront
tous cas présent la république suite
très près évidemment les
vos relations ce projet de loi parce que
ça s'inscrit aussi dans les engagements
qu'il avait pris lorsqu'il s'était rendu
à mayotte le sénat aussi un gérard
larcher a lancé une mission
d'information sur la question de
l'insécurité à mayotte il figure aussi
un volet immigration clandestine
l'examen du lien entre la question
migratoire et la question de la sécurité
vous soutenez cette démarche
le parlement étant est dans son rôle
après il fait plus fous il faut que ça
débouche toujours sur des propositions
opérationnelles concrètes
évitez aussi parfois les récupérations
politiques
voilà je suis moi même j'ai été du
parlementaire mois septembre dernier je
suis donc moi aussi sénateur à la base
donc on n'y a pas de raison mais je veux
dire ce qu'il faut c'est que c'est un
dossier compliqué mayotte donc il faut
qu'on soit sûr des choses techniques
précises concrètes opérationnelles
faisable et ne pas être dans une
gesticulation à quelques semaines de la
présidentielle pour faire du yaka fokon
mais là pour le coup je ne doute pas de
la sagesse sénatoriale sur ce sujet
dernière question politique sébastien
lecornu vous qui êtes issu des
républicains quel regard vous portez sur
ce qui se passe actuellement dans notre
ancienne famille politique
bon c'est un peu triste mais je ne me
réjouis pas de devoir une grande
formation politique qui est l'héritière
du rpr de jacques chirac de l'ump
d'alain juppé ou de nicolas sarkozy même
manière plus anciennes d'une famille
gaulliste voire complètement que la
crise de valeurs est la boussole donc
est complètement complètement déréglé et
au fond ça a commencé entre les deux
tours de l'élection présidentielle en
2017 lorsqu'ils n'ont pas su clairement
dire le bureau politique des
républicains donc pas su clairement dire
qu'il fallait voter pour emmanuel macron
contre marine le pen cette phrase n'a
pas été exprimée aussi simplement que
cela est malheureusement ça crée des
fractures qui sont qui sont profondes
alors aux républicains les avancées en
vue d'amener par la majorité
présidentielle c'est vrai
nous ne sommes pas chef de notre
position ça je pense qu'il faut qu'on
arrête avec ça sous entendu on aurait
des sinistres d'organiser ce bazar etc
non je dire si le parti des républicains
je parle pas des militants ou des élus
et des gens très bien hors rer faut pas
tout assimiler mais si la direction des
républicains n'arrivent plus à faire en
ville c'est pas de la faute des mesnel
macron gens s'ils ne sont pas capables
de sortir un projet clair avec des
valeurs claires est également aussi une
stratégie en matière d'alliances clair
bah ça c'est pour le coup leurs
responsabilités typiquement babineau mot
élection départementale qui est membre
historique des républicains qui est déjà
m'habille nommé depuis 2015 je suis mise
emmanuel macron depuis 2010 7 les
républicains viennent d'annoncer qu'ils
veulent exclure
ça n'a absolument aucun sens donc cette
dimension sectaire au bout d'un moment
elle fait perdre le fil et l'attention
que l'on peut avoir vis-à-vis des
français c'est ce qui malheureusement en
train de se produire c'est assez triste
et merci beaucoup merci sébastien
lecornu savoir était notre invité ce
matin merci beaucoup merci patrick roger
[Musique]